[موسيقى]
لا يدرك الناس عندما يمشون
بالخارج ، فهناك في الأساس متاجر بقالة
حول هذا الأمر ، وهذا شيء جميل
عن الطبيعة ، فجزء كبير من وظيفتي هو
التجول في الغابة وأقول أوه
ما هذا في الأرض ، التقطه و  تناولها ،
كما تعلم ، لدي هذا النوع من
الطبيعة الغريبة حيث لا أشعر بالرضا أبدًا عن
شيء ما إذا كنا نطبخ شيئًا ما ، كيف
يمكننا أن نفعله بشكل أفضل كيف يمكنك جعله
أكثر إثارة علينا أن نأكل
كبشر ، فلماذا لا نجعله أكثر
تجربة لا تنسى ، يمكنك اسمي
جيمس جوث ،
أنا فنان طهي
ومؤسس سهم نار في كثير من الأحيان ،
فنحن نعمل مع العملاء الذين ينفذون
رؤيتهم ، لذلك أشعر بالاطراء
الشديد لأن Coors Light تريد السماح لنا بإعداد
عشاء  سنفعل في وقت لاحق من هذا
الأسبوع حيث نقوم ببناء قائمة
مصممة حول الأنواع المحلية التي
تنمو في بيركشايرز
سمعة صغيرة لسبب أننا في
الشمال قليلاً لذا فإن مواسم النمو
قصيرة جدًا لذا فهي ص  حسناً ، بشأن
احتضان تلك اللحظة في الوقت المناسب ،
نحن لسنا على الأرض ، عليك أن
تضرب الأمر بشأن جيمس هو أنه لم
يوقف كريس أبدًا ، فهو يحتفظ بنفسه في مثل هذا
المستوى العالي وعندما يصل إلى حيث
يرتفع مستوى حلمه
هذا مصدر إلهام للغاية
لأنه يدفعك للاستمرار في
التحسن ، والاستمرار في التحسن
والاستمرار في التحسن.
أكبر شكل من أشكال الإلهام لدي هو الذهاب
إلى الغابة ، مما يجعلني أشعر بأن هذا
الدفء في صدري والشعر يقف فيه
الجزء الخلفي من رقبتي وأريد أن أكون
قادرًا على مشاركة ذلك مع الأشخاص ، هذا هو
تعبيري الفني لأتمكن من
تكرار تلك اللحظة في الوقت المناسب ،
فمن المعتاد أن يكون يوم 17 ساعة في الموقع ،
إنها تجربة كبيرة عندما يتعين عليك أن
تحبها و  لحسن الحظ ، لدي هذا في
فريق ، لذلك نحن في الموقع الآن ، وآمل
اليوم أن أحصل على بعض الأشياء
ولم نتمكن من الحصول عليها بسبب
الأمطار الغزيرة الليلة الماضية.
-الأخشاب
التي وجدتها على الإطلاق ستقطع كل هذا
النوع الصغير  بتلات هنا
وقليهم في الكثير من الزبدة والكثير
من الملح ، فقط قم بطيها بالخضروات
[موسيقى]
هذا التوت الأحمر الصغير طعمه
رائع مثل الفلفل الأسود وضعه في
طبق الليلة ،
مرحبًا بالجميع شكرًا جزيلاً على
حضوركم  الهدف هو تغيير حياتك إلى الأبد
اليوم ، أريد أن يأخذ الجميع هذه
اللحظة أكثر من مجرد التواجد هنا
وإدراك أن هذه ليست مجرد
أعشاب وحشائش ولكن النظر حولك
والتفكير في نجاح باهر هذا في الواقع مثل
متجر بقالة صالح للأكل هناك
أنا أحب مسرح ما نقوم به ، وهذا
شيء أريد أن أكون قادرًا على منح
الناس المسرح الترفيه الذي
يعرضهم لشيء لم
يروه حقًا أن يكون هناك لحظة في الحياة
سوف يبتعد عنها الناس
ستكون ذكرى  لقد تم حرقها بداخلها
إلى الأبد كما ترى من الواضح أن هذا الآيس
كريم متورط هنا ولكن هذا
آيس كريم من خشب البتولا مصنوع عن طريق نقع
شرائح من خشب البتولا والحليب الكريمي
والسكر بين عشية وضحاها  إذا نظرت إلى
فوقك ، فقد قمنا بالفعل بجمع لحاء الصنوبر
ثم وضعه في دقيق قمح كامل ، لذا
فهذه عبارة عن نباتات صغيرة ،
هل استمتعت بكل شيء ، نعم ،
شكرًا لك مرة أخرى على
تخصيص الوقت بصدق ، فهذا يعني حقًا كل شيء
بالنسبة لنا.  كجزء من هذه
التجربة ، ستفتح
أعينك على الطبيعة لأن هناك الكثير
مما نسيناه ، لذا نشكرك مرة أخرى على
حضورنا وأريد فقط أن
أتوقف لحظة لأشكر أربع لايت
لمنحنا الفرصة لرواية قصتنا ، Cheers
[  موسيقى]
أنت